huge number of journalists believe that
the government is spying on them yeah
that's right Pew Research did a poll of
454 media figures and yeah a huge
percentage take my word for it but we're
going to show you some numbers right
here believe that the government is
spying on them that's right so basically
sixty-four percent of journalists who
were polled believe that the government
is either collecting data on them only
thirty-four percent say that the
government isn't and when it comes to
national government security and foreign
affairs probably the most important that
this is where the government secrets are
NSA stuff that we talked about all time
all that 71 percent think the
government's collecting data on them and
other journalists so this is just any
old journalist is a local TV guy
whatever it is sixty-two percent of them
think that the government is collecting
data and spying on them this is
incredibly disheartening and scary and
it makes you wonder what these people
are inherently hiding when they're
reporting because they don't want the
government to crack down on them we know
that self-censorship happens all the
time this is a wheelhouse issue for the
young turks so I'll go to you first I
don't know I feel like maybe I'm gonna
be the one that's on the other end of
this but I don't put much credence to
this study and I mean this links to the
journalists who answered not that it's a
bad study they asked them answered right
um but so you think it's maybe them
being a little selfish or down a little
bit yeah yes and yes I'm sure plenty of
journalists do get spied upon but if
you're the anchor in WXYZ Montana local
6.com down they don't give a [ __ ] about
what you're doing so like so again like
there's ones who are exposing big things
or have certain sources that are deep in
certain kinds of you know investigative
parts or deep canals of the government
yeah they probably are watching you that
makes sense we have proof of that
actually yeah it has happened but then
the perception now that stretches to
what 64% yeah that number was I think
maybe thirty five percent of the need to
come right alright so let's get just a
little more information on the pole
first and then and I will jump back
alright so seven in ten said they
believe that the government has spied on
their calls emails and online searches
eight in ten believe just being a
journalist jumps the chance of being
spied on eighty percent just by being a
journalist that's what they think of
fourteen percent say in the past 12
months such concerns have kept them
from pursuing a story or reaching out to
a particular source or blend them to
consider leaving investigative
journalism all together so that's all
talk about about self-censorship that if
you think this is happening then you
might not want to report on a story so I
think your point is is well taken yet
guys there in the middle country doing
local stories probably not that
important there also may be an element
to this where reporters think that
they're more important than they
actually are so maybe that's why they
intended so high but I don't want to
discount uh legitimate concerns when we
know the government is still prosecuting
reporters plenty of examples is I feel
like they're spying on everybody I feel
like we're all having our calls and
emails monitor matter what we do yeah
and so why not journalists you know what
makes them so special i mean yeah i
think a lot of them sort of fall into
the general umbrella of just general you
know hinky behavior on the on behalf of
the people who are monitoring this stuff
but sure i think that certainly if
you're in a position to actually do some
damage or reveal some damning truths
then you your debt that puts you in the
crosshairs so is this Obama's biggest
failure because it seems to me that we
had our like a six month period where we
were talking about the NSA all the time
right Snowden and everything all the
documents being released and all that
and people were starting to get outraged
Obama said he was going to do some stuff
they kind of were implying maybe it's
just metadata not actual you know
tangible information and emails things
like that and for you know we're not
listening to your phone calls we're just
watching we're just watching we know how
long they are you know all that stuff
that they can always explain away but
who do you believe so is this really his
failure that this is a guy who came in
saying transparent transparent
transparent and by every account this is
the least transparent administration
that ever and then think that was his I
think it's very was saying how
transparent is gonna be because I mean
it's probably the least transparent
because it's 2015 08 to 16 now if any
other president was in from 08 I mean
yeah fri wait till 16 hey you're gonna
be the least transparent in history
because just cuz you the technology yeah
just because and who your surroundings
up with you're not going to put people
in place that are going to not be
paranoid and that I'm not their job is
to think hey let's protect this
president this administration our
secrets are moves by any means necessary
and if a president walks and it goes no
you're not you're the head of the CIA
whatever
you're not gonna do it then you okay in
there and do it like these these are
these are high up individuals who have
big egos and have power too but you're
to your point about the the lack of
outrage I don't know that Cecily Obama's
fall did you see the thing that it was a
slate or somebody did the beginning of
the year where it was the outrage
calendar of last year and Lily every day
there was this new thing some celebrity
said something or some government
revelation was made no one has the
attention span anymore to stay mad about
anything for too long right remember how
sandy hook was going to finally change
you know the gun laws in this country no
like if we can't hold on to it anymore
because they're just new [ __ ] in the
pipeline all that's right and we talk
about this all the time so last summer
it was you know make something with
Syria and then we move to Ebola and then
we move to Cosby and then we move to
Brian Williams and now John still like
that's just the nature of it so but i
think they sort of prey on that know you
think that the government and and NSA
know that that they prey on the fact
that we can't pay attention for more
than three so much so that when people
do pay attention something for more
people who are listening complain about
they go okay enough of this move on yes
unless unless it's Benghazi in your fox
news that one managed to stay aloft for
a long time but yeah generally speaking
people yet they if you stay on to
something too long you're a crank now
because you won't let it go yeah two
weeks later yeah and by the way by the
way if you want an example of how
dangerous this actually is today the day
that we're taping this Obama supposedly
later today is going to Congress to
finally get war authorization he's gonna
go for three years against Isis he's
gonna be gone by the end of the three
years and of course when they put a
timetable it never means anything cuz
anything happening blah blah blah but
that means that we've been at war in
Syria which is a different country than
Iraq and we never got authorization all
this time and part of the reason as I've
said many times in show is because
people get so distracted that you don't
even real they're like our bet we're
bombing Syria now and nobody thinks
about it no one goes well what what
going back your 1984 quote from the
previous segment that I've always been
at war with OSHA Nia you know I guess I
can't even focus anymore just like
somebody somewhere were attacking and
over the news used to be our least news
of a big deal was we're going to war now
the huge news is were not stopping oh my
gaijin you hear the breaking news we're
not going to fight if we continue to
fight that's is fine right not that's
actually a really great point all right
so final thoughts who do you fear more
uh is it the government or the hackers
cuz I don't know which I fear more at
this point because both you know want
your information both can do nefarious
things with your information uh would
you feel more the they're almost kind of
molding now the man maybe they are ideas
on its payroll hackers and those guys
can was they found it snapped up so um
in that case probably the government
because then they have the hackers and
then they're looking to find the ones i
mean got the Snowden's who will tell us
what he found and that guy's you know he
is no chance yeah so those i mean they
still have you mean you don't want to
come back to america like melissa
harris-perry said come back and you know
face the music i like Miss Erica yeah
yeah so I mean they they they have more
to lose i think you know there's their
barren two more of a scrutiny from the
government themselves yeah yeah who do
you fear more i don't know i was still
doomed when i come on the show I don't
think about a lot and then you parade
these like robot dogs and spying
televisions I'm like perfect you see
what I'm doing I want people to think
about this stuff with more than you know
two seconds that's we're gonna be the
end of the world's end basically we're
all of our screens are dead and we're
wandering around starting campfires and
like you know shivering on that note I
got a like and comment down below